it's that time again to talk to you all
the latest games in new releases and
this week forget colon eugene because ms
walker is kicking ass with a neon dash
in the first dlc for infamous second son
explore seattle once more in a time
before Delson and if you enjoyed hearing
the name Delson over and over again as
much as i did prepared for hearing the
name fetch that's right fetch first
light comes out august 26 and by now if
you haven't played them you've already
heard about the post-apocalyptic monster
infested Russian world of metro 2033 and
last light with a rock-solid 60 frames
per second and triple native resolutions
and previous consoles the game looks and
feels brand spankin new there are all
new features including new AI weapon
handling and customizations stealth
kills non-lethal take downs but most
importantly the mask wipe ya with that
mask rubber over remix August 26
remember last year when Madden released
madden NFL 25 because it was a century
old well that naming convention is dead
because it's 2014 and it's time for
madden NFL 15 the latest in american
football sports gets released on current
and last gen xbox and playstation with
the ever loved Richard Sherman on the
cover get your block on August 26 this
week all good things must come to an end
as the walking dead season 2 finale
episode 5 no going back comes out on pc
mac playstation 3 and PS vita first with
more to come in the next few days with
winter coming food running out and a
baby to take care of it's going to be
one of the most emotional episodes of
all time so hold on to your butts
clementines conclusion comes out August
26 uh what's this now why it's Lich Tom
battlemage finally coming out from the
belly of early access and into full-on
super for real release on PC play is a
first-person caster with limitless
magical power none of that running out
of mana crap smash your enemies and loot
their very souls for essence that will
get you even more spells become a battle
ma che August 26 for further details
visit gamespot com release dates are
based on retailer listings and are
subject to change see you next week